[music]
>> Number six
is
that you have to be gentle in your
approach.
You have to be soft in your speech.
Allah
in Surah
chapter number 20 verse number 43 44
addressing Musa
Allah
says oh Musa go to Firaun who has
transgressed in the land and speak
gently to him. Speak mildly to him.
For there is a hope
that he may enter the fold of Islam.
He may start fearing Allah
wa ta'ala.
So this is the way how Allah
is teaching his prophets.
Do you know Firaun?
The biggest enemy of Allah at that time
who claimed divinity to himself. Allah
is telling Musa
you're going towards this tyrant. You're
going to meet this tyrant, this
persecutor, the biggest enemy of Allah.
But be gentle to him.
Be soft-spoken to him.
There is a hope
that he may enter the fold of Islam. He
may start fearing Allah wa ta'ala.
So a da'ee of Allah should be gentle in
his speech.
He should be kind towards the people.
And Rasul
it's a hadith of Muslim in the kitab
al-adab in the book of good manners. He
said
whenever gentleness enters anything it
beautifies it.
And whenever
gentleness enters anything it beautifies
it. And whenever harshness enters
anything it spoils it.
So as a da'ee of Allah
you have to be gentle towards the
people.
You have to be kind and soft-spoken to
the people. But that does not mean that
those enemies of Allah who are attacking
Islam, who are spreading misconceptions
about Islam, speaking ill about Islam
and the message of Islam, that does not
mean you cannot debate with them.
That we have already spoken. Allah
says in Surah chapter 16 verse 125. He
tells us
debate with them, reason with them
in the ways that are best and most
gracious.
So even in the debate Allah
is asking to conduct us in a good
manner.
And lastly
Allah
says in the glorious Quran
in many places discussing about the
prophets of Allah.
He tells that the prophets of Allah were
always optimistic.
They never lost hope.
They always had a good hope and a belief
that the outcome would be good.
And the best example
is wa ta'ala wa sallam.
He continued preaching for 950
years.
And he continued to do that without
losing hope.
And Rasulullah
wa sallam too
he did not lose hope at any instance of
his lifetime.
He continued with the message of Allah.
He went on the 13 years of Mecca in
life. He was persecuted. He was
tortured. But he never lost hope.
Allah took him to Medina.
There Allah
helped the Muslims to establish
themselves and the victory came to him,
the Fatah Mecca.
So as a da'ee of Allah one should never
lose hope.
We should persist
in always giving the message of Allah
and always hope for good results.
These were in short I would say the
bullet points
of the characteristics of a good da'ee.
If a person does not base his da'wa on
these pillars that which I just
discussed then the entire foundation,
the entire building of his da'wa falls
down.
If the foundation becomes weak, if the
pillars become weak
then the building is sure to collapse.
So as da'ees of Allah we should all
make sure that we strengthen our
foundation. We strengthen our pillars.
We become sincere towards Allah.
We acquire knowledge.
We invite people towards Islam through
hikmah.
We also be gentle and polite in our
speech.
We make sure that we hold on to patience
and perseverance. Always hope for good
and become most importantly a misali.
That our actions match our words. With
this I would like to conclude my talk
with the words from the glorious Quran
from Surah
chapter 41 verse number 33. Allah
says
and who is better in speech other than
the one who calls people towards Allah,
does righteous deeds and says I am of
those who are Muslims.
Wa assalam alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
If the brothers have any questions on
the topic of characteristics of a da'ee
then they are most welcome to ask.
Inshallah
we will take the first question from
brother Abdul Malik Badeges. Bismillah
Rahman Rahim. Thank you very much for
the opportunity given.
I have some questions, very simple ones.
You can ask the most important first.
Okay, but it's related.
It's related. Okay, so what are the
differences actually between the
da'ees nowadays? Can I say modern da'ee?
Da'ees nowadays, the characteristic
between da'ee nowadays and da'ees at
past.
And as we know everything is digitally
facilitated. We can have everything in
our hands, PDF, all the books and
everything. Do you think people nowadays
can be even better than Muslim scholars
at past?
Brother Abdul Malik Badeges has asked a
very relevant question.
That
the present day that which we live in
the modern technology and he says can we
call the da'ees as modern da'ees? Can we
be better than the scholars of the past?
Brother
let me tell you if by modern you mean
using the modern technology and the best
technology available to spread the
message of Allah then alhamdulillah you
should be modern.
And this da'wa training program
is a benchmark being set for the
Muslims, for the da'ees of Allah to do
the best of da'wa through the best of
means, the most modern technology, the
4K cameras, the 8K cameras.
The best of stages, the best of sets. If
this is what you mean by modern then
alhamdulillah as Muslims, as da'ees
living in this age we have to be modern.
But if you mean to say by modern means
that you compromise on the rulings of
the Quran and Sunnah in this way, if you
say modern da'ee means this then
definitely you should not be a modern
da'ee in inverted commas.
This is not modernism. We cannot
compromise
on any ruling of the Quran and Sunnah.
If by using any modern technology, if
you are breaking any single rule of the
Quran or the Sunnah of the prophet wa
sallam then this technology or this
modern technology becomes haram upon us.
Hope I've answered your question,
brother.
I guess brother Reman had raised his
hand first.
So can we pass on the mic to brother
Reman?
Assalam alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
I just want you to repeat the main
bullet points of what is the
characteristics of the da'ee. Just the
bullet titles. I mean not in the detail
you have to give another lecture, just
the bullet points so that we can
remember again. Jazakallah khair.
Brother Reman is requesting me to repeat
the bullet points or the seven points
which I covered in the lecture. Brother,
if you had paid attention I just didn't
say it once.
In the end of my lecture I again
repeated those points. But since you
have asked me the question, let me
quickly tell you. Number one is ikhlas,
sincerity.
That a da'ee of Allah should only have
the intention to please Allah.
If he's doing it for fame, name then
this is not the right foundation of
da'wa. Number two is you have to acquire
knowledge.
You should have the correct knowledge of
Islam before you preach Islam.
Number three is that you have to be
gentle and polite.
Number four
you should call the people with Hikmah,
with wisdom.
Number five, you have to have patience
and perseverance.
Number six, you have to be misali. You
have to be an exemplary.
You cannot contradict your own words.
And number seven, you should always hope
for good. You should always have an
optimistic view about doing Dawah. Hope
I've answered your question, brother
Imam.
Yes, brother Firdous. As-salamu alaykum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh. Wa alaykum
salaam.
>> Okay, on your point number two, uh with
talking about acquiring knowledge.
The issue here is that
how much knowledge is required in order
for someone to to start doing Dawah?
Because you might have somebody who says
that you need to memorize this, you have
to memorize that, or maybe you have to
know Arabic. If you do not know Arabic,
can you do Dawah, this and that. So,
maybe can you just qualify and elaborate
a little bit on that point. Thank you so
much. Brother Firdous has asked a very
common question that which some of the
Muslims have about
getting into the field of Dawah without
any proper knowledge. By knowledge,
brother Firdous, if they mean to say
academic qualification,
then they have mistaken.
Academic qualification is not a
criterion for a person to get into the
field of Dawah.
If you have to give you an example, and
Dr. Zakir Naik earlier gave the example,
one of the best icons of Dawah
in the previous century was none other
than Sheikh Ahmed Deedat.
And what academic qualification did he
have?
He did not acquire knowledge from any of
the Islamic universities.
He did not learn Arabic as a language.
Though alhamdulillah,
as a da'ee of Allah, he knew Arabic to a
certain extent, but he did not acquire
expertise in Arabic language. But was he
not effective in his Dawah?
This man alone was sufficient to shake
the entire Christendom.
So, by academic qualification does not
mean that a person is qualified to do
Dawah only if he has a degree in Islam,
only if he has a graduation in Sharia,
in Hadith.
This is not
the major factor which should make you
do Dawah.
Or you should come into Dawah only if
you have the academic qualification.
This is alhamdulillah mustahab.
This is recommended, but that does not
mean if you do not have the right
qualification, you do not do Dawah. But
if you ask the extent of knowledge, I
already clarified in my speech. Allah's
messenger sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said in Hadith of Sahih al-Bukhari,
volume number four, Hadith number 3461,
Rasul sallallahu alayhi wasallam said,
"Ballighu anni walaw ayah."
Convey from me even if it be one single
ayah.
So, even if you know one ayah,
and if you know it correctly from the
Quran, from the Sunnah,
then as a Muslim, you're obliged to
convey to the others.
Even if it be one ayah.
Hope I've answered your question.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah. Allah. Ya Rabbi.
Allah.